hello uh my name is yuval tagan
and i will present the joint work with
eval filmos
daniel kane and shy moran
it is called the entropy of flies
playing 20 questions with a liar
so as you could have guessed this paper
is about a 20 questions game
and i will start by describing a simple
variant of this game
so it is played by two parties alice
and bob where bob will think of some
object
x from a finite set of objects
and alice's goal is to reveal this
object
using yes no questions so for example
let's say that bob would think of a
vegetable a dog or a cat
and so first of all alice will ask
whether this is a vegetable
and if the answer is yes then she knows
that the object is a potato
and otherwise she can ask another
question that distinguishes between the
cat and the dog
and in this simple variant the goal of
alice
is to ask as few questions as possible
and reveal the object
so here the optimal strategy
can be by doing uh
binary search over some ordering of the
objects
and this will ask login questions
now let's add a complication to this
game
and now we allow bob to lie
at most k times
but we still want alice to always detect
the correct object
regardless of the lies
and in this setting the optimal strategy
of alice
will ask logan plus k log log n
questions this means that every line
adds additional loglog and
questions that artists should ask
and this was shown a tight
even with sharp constants up to lower
order terms
already in the 80s
so now we presented the setting
20 question with lines and now let's add
another complication
of this to this game uh
so so here we assume a distributional
setting
where the element that bob selects
is drawn from some distribution rather
than being arbitrary
so we assume a distribution mu where mu
i
is the probability of both to select the
element
x i we further assume that alice knows
this prior distribution and her goal
is to minimize the number of questions
that
she asks in expectation
where the expectation is taken over this
distribution
over objects
so let's give an example
so here we have the same example as
before but now we have a probability
distribution
over the objects for example a potato
had a probability of one half a cat 0.3
and a dog 0.2 and
now let's calculate the expected number
of questions that alice asks
in this strategy so potato has one
question
so that contributes 0.5 times 1.
a cut has probability 0.3 in two
questions
that contributes at 0.3 times 2 and in
adult contributes 0.2 times 2
and in total we have one half questions
on
average
uh so now that we
presented the distribution environment
let's ask what is the optimal strategy
assuming that bob tells no lies
only uh the correct answers
so in this case there is a very simple
solution
that is directly applying
a huffman code and
asks at most at the entropy
of the distribution plus one questions
in expectation
where the entropy of the distribution mu
is just the sum
overall probabilities i of the
probability
mu i of element i
times log one over the probability
and the entropy captured the number of
questions
that the alice should ask in the optimal
strategy
uh and now after we uh
presented two generalizations one
uh adding lies and
secondly uh adding some distribution
over the elements
so in this and these two uh
settings were already studied in prime
work
so in this work we study a mixture of
these settings
where we both have lights and a
distributional setting
so here bob will sample x i from some
distribution
and is light to light most k types
and the goal of alice is to reveal the
correct object
with probability 1 while minimizing the
number of
questions asked in expectation
and in order to present the result of
this paper
and compare it with the prior work
we have this table
so here we see that in the deterministic
setting with no lies
and the optimal strategy asks login
questions
and with slides we have log n plus k log
log n
now in the distributional setting the
login
is replaced by the entropy
and in this paper we showed that in the
distribution
setting with slice we can further
replace
the log log n with a quantity that we
term
h2 of a distribution
which is just as sum over all
probabilities i
of the probability mu i times
log log 1 over mu i
and this matches
uh uh the same guarantee as in the
deterministic setting
if we take mu to be the uniform
distribution
over the elements
now we have both upper and lower bound
that
match with sharp constants
up to lower order terms
okay so so this was the result
uh on on
a 20 questions game and we further want
to say that this is computed
efficiently and using a binary search
like
algorithm that uses comparison queries
and for this reason we can apply
this result to uh sorting
with comparison queens
and here we have a setting where we
have a sorting algorithm that has
comparison queries
but at most k of them can
actually give you the wrong answer
and we further assume that there is some
prior
distribution over the possible
permutations
and that the permutation is drawn
from this distribution
for example we can assume that the
array is already
closed to be sorted
so in this setting we know some prior
over over there possible permutations
and here we can show that
the analog enter that
comes in the deterministic setting
can be replied by the entropy
of the set of possible permutations
so after discussing the sorting
application
we move to the proof so first we discuss
the upper bound
and then we move to the lower bound
so in the upper bound we show that for
the 20 questions game
there is a strategy of alice that us
at most the entropy plus
k h2 of the distribution
questions on expectation
and first we present the
an algorithm which is a binary search
algorithm
for the distribution distributional
setting
with no lies and this
is due to gilbert and more from 59
and let's see how this binary search
algorithm works
so uh it places each element
x i on the segment zero one
at some point p i
then it performed a binary search to
find
uh the point corresponding to the
element
and the binary search is very simple
first it asks whether the point
is greater than 0.5
let's say that bob says no and i'll
continue
whether it's greater than 0.25
no whether it's greater than 1 8
and let's say here that bob says yes and
now we know
that the object must
be x2 that's light in point
p2
so now that we've shown how to perform
this binary research
i would also like to explain how to play
the elements on the segment
so the high level idea is that
elements with higher probability
uh we should ask less questions in order
to reveal them
and that's because we are interested in
the expected number of questions
so we are interested more on minimizing
the questions for the
more probable elements
and for this reason element with higher
probability should be
more space around in the interval
because the more spacing that they have
the faster it takes to find them
in particular for each element i
we will create an interval
of length mu i namely the length
is the probability
and then we will place the
element in the middle of its
corresponding
interval now it
is very easy to show that
the number of questions that are
required to locate
each element i is at most
log one over its probability plus two
now taking an expectation over all the
elements
you get that the expected number of
questions
is at about the entropy plus two
and this is already very very close to
optimal
so we showed a binary search algorithm
that is close to the optimal algorithm
in the setting of no lines
now let's
explain how we can locate
and correct lies
so first we give some example and assume
that
the true element is x7 line in point p7
and that the first question uh
is answered in a lie by bob
so bob said that p7 is less than
one-half and
now notice the following property
in each consecutive question
p7 will be greater
than the separator so the true answer
to all consecutive questions should be
greater than
so it is greater than one quarter yes
it is greater than 0.375 yes
is greater than 0.43 yes
so now if bob doesn't lie we will see
many many consecutive greater than
answer
and we use this property to
locate suspicious question answers
and correct them
and let's first give the first example
for a suspicious
uh answer so let's say the answer was
less than
and all consecutive
answers were greater than
and many of them
now and this looks very suspicious uh to
be a lie
and let's look at another example so
remember that bob can in fact lie
even after uh his first live
so uh we can there can be
a k minus one additional lies
after uh the the first slide
and any uh sequence of a lesson answer
followed by many greater than answers
and at most k minus 1
lesson answers will also be
suspicious
and now let's look at the non-suspicion
uh
non-suspicious case and here we have a
lesson answer
followed by uh more
than a k lesson answers
in this setting uh the
marked lesson answer must
be correct because otherwise
uh there couldn't be so many a lesson
answer that follow this answer
so here we have
some intuition on how to find the
suspicious answers and now
i will give you a sketch of the
algorithm that uses
this intuition so first it executes
uh the binary search on the line as
a gilbert moore algorithm that i
described to you before and we
do this until we
find uh until we encounter
a suspicious answer
so here we have a suspicious answer
which is a lesson
followed by many greater than
and not so many other lesson answers
and once we find a suspicious answer
we remove all the
subsequent answers
and we verify this answer
by asking it 2k plus 1 times
and then we take the majority of
all the repeated
time that we asked this question
and the majority must be correct because
bob
can lie at most k times
then we continue uh
up to the point that either we find
another suspicious answer or
until the binary search
terminates
and once it terminates it returns some
object and we want to verify that this
is the correct object
and we do this again by asking 2k plus
2k plus 1 times whether this is the true
object
and if the answer is positive then we
just
output this object we found it and
otherwise we also have to delete some
questions and keep going
so now the analysis claimed that
the number of questions uh deleted
due to a suspicious answers
is not very high
and in this way
we get our final bound
on the performance of the algorithm
so that's it for the upper bound and now
let's move to the lower bound
and here we want to show that alice asks
at least the entropy plus
k h2 of mu questions on average
and before explaining the lower bound
with uh lies we start with the lower
bound with no lies
and here we use some lemma from
information theory that states that
in order to reveal a random variable
that is distributed
according to some distribution mu
we need to communicate at least
the entropy of mu bits of information
on average now
because at most one bit
of information is communicated in each
question then the number of questions
has to be at least
the entropy of the distribution
so that is a very simple uh lower bound
in uh in the setting of no
lines and now let's move to the vetting
with light
and here we want a larger
lower bound
so uh in this so uh
what we show that in this case
once alice reveals the element
x she also reveals
the locations of the lies
and we denote by y the vector of
the positions of the lines of bob
and because alice learns not only x but
also why
the number of bits that had to be
communicated to her
is at least the joint entropy between
x and between y
which is the vector of lies
and if we compute this quantity
we get exactly what we want
and there is a very short proof in our
paper so that's it for the lower bound
and now let's make a conclusion so we
had an
optimal algorithm for 20 questions with
slides
that is using comparison queries and it
is
computationally efficient a matching
lower bound and an application to
a noisy starting thanks for listening